[Music]
welcome everyone to the Stanford
Graduate School of Business alumni panel
for the western region I'm gonna go
ahead and just get started talking about
what you guys can expect today as I
mentioned at the beginning my name is
ELISA Coble I'm a member of the MBA
admissions team here at Stanford I'm
joined today with five panelists and the
focus today is an hearing the
perspectives of folks who are residing
in currently the western region of the
United States and so we'll get to hear
firsthand experiences of people who have
been to the GSB and this session
specifically is 45 minutes long just to
set some expectations we'll start off
with introductions with our panelists
and then open it up for Q&A so I will be
looking at the Q&A pod for questions and
trying to moderate a discussion amongst
with our panelists this will be 45
minutes we'll do some introductions and
like I said feel free to submit
questions throughout I will end this
session talking about other types of
events that we offer but today we're
going to really jump right in to
questions and answers with our panelists
if you're looking for more information
on our program on admissions criteria
and things like that we do have info
sessions that we offer throughout the
summer the next few months and we
encourage you to check on our events
page and for more but I will talk about
more of those events at the end of this
so again thank you everyone to joining
today we are so excited to have you and
for this panel and because this is a
session that is focused on the western
region and we have panels this summer
focused on regions focused on industries
and I wanted to share because this is
the western region a bit of information
about our class of 2021 profile as you
can see about 66 countries are
represented
good in the GSB class so an incredibly
global class of students we have about
420 students in each class but again
today's focus is the western region and
as you'll see I'm in coming in class of
2021 about 64% of students united's from
the United States um I want to take some
time to have each of our panelists today
introduce themselves
we're joined like I said by five great
panelists very excited to have all of
them here today to share their
perspectives I'm gonna ask each of them
to go around and state their name their
class here and if each of you could
share perhaps your favorite academic
experience so maybe a class project
faculty what was your favorite acting
experience when you were at the GSB and
we'll have each of you answer that and
then we'll get started with more
questions so Norris why don't we start
with you for the introduction so again
my name is Norris and I graduated class
of 2019 and one academic program I
really liked was the step where Stanford
seeing my exchange program that did in
the summer of 2008 or fall over 2018 and
that was really cool because I got to
learn about tech talk on bites of Dance
before it became super huge in the
United States I'm sunny why don't we go
next video hi everyone my name is sunny
Kumar I'm a graduate of the MBA program
as well as the MD program from Stanford
my favorite academic experience was
leading a GST a global study trip to
Greece where we looked at how the
economic crisis from 2009 affected their
healthcare system even more relevant
today as we're all facing another
healthcare crisis and we're going to
kind of adapt in this situation great
Thank You Marlo I know you're on I'm by
phone and we'd love to have you
introduce yourself excellent
hi everyone this is Marlo apologies
again that I don't have video but quick
background on me class of 2016
I
currently works in in private equity now
in Los Angeles and sig my favorite
academic experience was actually
probably taking the search fun class and
learning a little bit about almost a
micro private equity type world and
combined with entrepreneurship I think
it was a really interesting way Thank
You Marianna for me it was the
electronic business class with Jaime
Middleton I know it sounds so basic was
about Airbnb
and I was like this is crazy that's
awesome thanks for sharing and video
well have you introduce yourself now
everyone I'm Vidya I graduated from the
GSB in 2012 and now I'm up in Seattle
working for the strategic investment
fund at the Gates Foundation my favorite
academic experience at the GSB was the
bio design innovation class which I hope
they're still teaching I'm not sure
which is kind of an interdisciplinary
class between the business school
medical school and a bunch of the
engineering programs where you basically
have like a specific medical need that
you're you choose and you develop a
medical device together kind of go
through the entire process of the design
process to come up with something and
figure out the regulatory pathway and my
team the year that I did it they were
focused on global health needs and I got
to basically develop a saliva based
diagnostic for neonatal jaundice it was
just such a cool experience and like
working across people with several
backgrounds so I love that great thank
you so much for sharing um I see
actually a question that's a great
follow-up to you guys sharing your
favorite academic experience
we've got asked really about the
leadership courses
in leadership curriculum at the GSB I
was wondering if maybe one or two of you
could share at the leadership courses
that you maybe took whether it was
leadership labs or an elective that you
took or executive challenge this is a
question from Andrew Hugh what was most
transformative for you and really how
did it help you develop your leadership
skills so kind of a follow up academic
question why don't we start with Norris
to answer that sure so one thing about
leadership labs that I've taken with me
it's pretty basic it's like the action
impact feedback format and and our
startup we have monthly climate checks
where we actually utilize that and it
seems to be a pretty good way where you
get specific information about something
you did and how impacts others pretty
simple but it's often people forget that
you know they don't actually know what
they did to make them feel that way so
it's good to remember that awesome
thanks for sharing and sunny could you
share about leadership perhaps something
that helped you develop your leadership
skills or helped kind of on your
transformation absolutely for me the
most impactful academic experience I had
related to leadership was a course
called interpersonal dynamics that many
of you may be familiar with the core
nature of this course is to help you in
a small group learn how to communicate
more effectively and in a different
style than I think most people are aware
of coming from a medical background we
often are in positions where we're
delivering hard news challenging news
but I actually think unequivocally the
best communication experience and
learning I got was from interpersonal
dynamics during my entire tenure at
Stanford I see another question out
there just about career pivoting and
when we shared this screen for a few of
you there were there were some of you
who did pivot
careers I'd love to hear from we'll
start with Mariana about what you were
doing before the GSB and maybe how the
GSB helped you prepare for what you want
it to do after and then I'd also love
for Marlo to follow up and answer that
tune but we'll start with Mariana yes
so career pivoting is very common before
business school I was in consulting in
private equity and I thought I was going
to go back to probably afterwards that's
what I was getting myself towards
actually they're putting into text not a
Facebook and a lot of that just came
from exposure like I think that's one of
the best things about Stanford is that
the alumni come back obviously and in
courses you hear from a lot of folks who
are you know running major companies
industries perspective to being on the
East Coast for me financing and salting
were the biggest and most important
industries and then I come to the west
coast and I realized actually was a
whole other world out there and so for
me was an exposure to you know the
industry of tech and then narrowing once
I figured out that's where I wanted to
go things that helped coursework just to
get like the survey of all the things
and then the internship it's basically
like a free pass to do anything so I
contacted this founder who I know asked
to be his number two and basically just
followed him around the world for my
summer and that's how I figure out it
was definitely the industry for me and
don't be surprised if you go in thinking
one thing and something entirely
different
afterwards great Thank You Marlo do you
want to answer that - I know you've
committed when you came to business
school - sure
some for business school I was in
consulting on a kind of very traditional
path to return to consulting then you
got to the GSB and similarly got exposed
to a bunch of new people a bunch of new
ideas and realized I was actually really
interested in investing and so I was
pretty fortunate that I realized that
fairly early and ultimately worked with
the Career Center to pursue an inter
in private equity on the East Coast had
a great experience realized it was what
I wanted to do kind of full time after
the GSD and so ultimately decided to go
down that path and so I've been in Los
Angeles doing private equity for the
last four years kind of building upon
some of what I learned in my internship
and really glad that I got the chance
over that three-month period to try out
a different career because I think
otherwise as much as I really enjoyed
consulting I think it's been exciting to
make a change great thanks to you guys
there's actually a question from Anna in
the audience and she's kind of
piggybacking off of this career pivoting
question so I'll follow up with Mariana
and Marlo but then probably have someone
else chime in that really is about how
many of you came to business school with
the intent to pivot and how many of you
were expose to something while here and
and so many of you are getting such
different things out there that I'd love
to hear you know a follow-up to Mariana
and Marlo and maybe a video you could
chime in here too so Mariana why don't
you it sounded like you were exposed to
things as you came so maybe you didn't
have been hitting but if you could share
more of what you were thinking as you
came into this as well yeah I different
geography and different skill when I got
to business school are they sweep it out
that I wanted to create and like for me
I got valued from like actually creating
things that without me in the world
wouldn't exist I wasn't getting that
from investing and so just became like
really clear where I was getting my
energy from and I think that's been a
good in my life you know what gives you
can try on a few things done a career
that you know because no one has an
interest in line for two years people
aren't going into what's the Marla maybe
you could chime in and yeah yeah I would
say mine was somewhat exposure based as
well I mean I had a combination of kind
of meeting classmates and putting faces
to the career with respect to something
I had heard of but didn't know quite as
much about until I met individuals who
were in that path or come from that path
I hope took a couple courses I took a an
investing cloud a couple investing
classes I kept some financial modeling
classes I hope to join some clubs I was
in a couple investing clubs are exactly
clubs and whatnot and I think that
helped also just sort of surround me
with new ideas that made me realize that
was something I was interested in
Nvidia I know you also switched careers
when you came did you was that kind of a
goal of yours to pivot when you started
at the GSB I think for me there was
definitely intent to pivot so my
background before coming to the to the
GSB as I worked in kind of traditional
finance in New York at Goldman first
starting on the investment banking side
then working within the kind of crop
hedge fund and I knew when I was doing
that that I was like gaining skills but
I wanted to apply those skills somewhere
very different in the course of my
career but sound that when you work that
many hours a day or a week you can't
really spend a lot of time thinking
about the transition and for me my
passion area had always been around
International Development and I think
through actually my time at Goldman I
gained a lot of interest in healthcare
so I became interested in globe
health but the problem that I faced was
there's like a bazillion things you can
go do in global health and I have this
like particular set of skills that
relates to kind of understanding
companies and the private sector works
and so how do I figure out what that
right role is for me so I came in to
Business School with the intent to
explore that's there not knowing what
the answer would be but wanting to look
at you know maybe working for the
government or multilateral agencies
maybe working for companies on the
ground or for US companies that we're
kind of trying to send innovation over
there and maybe staying in the
investment field which is something a
function I really liked but having that
investment be much more kind of geared
towards bringing innovation to the
developing world and I did my internship
at the Gates Foundation in which I feel
so grateful to have been at Stanford
because that year when 2011 my summer
was the first year they offered an
internship and the only places they
offered it were Stanford Business School
and you know just because actually the
CEO of the Gates Foundation at that time
had was a Stanford alum it's like the
only reason was very fortuitous I
actually did my internship totally out
of investing focused on global health
got a lot of exposure and found this
team that I now work on which was kind
of the perfect combination and the
skills and the interest on my way there
but I assumed a lot of like searching
like the other said in classes and
projects and he mixes which are like
these small internships you can do over
the summer I worked in India so it was
just like a great kind of test ground I
think to try different things great I'd
love for Sonny to came in here with
about intent to pivot but I'm gonna
broaden it a bit for you specifically we
have a few questions in the audience
about dual degrees and coming to the GSB
and and kind of how is that possible I'm
so I'd love for you to share when you
decided doing a dual degree was the
right thing for you and just what your
intent or original thinking was at that
time and maybe how it played out as you
went to business sure absolutely I'm
giving you guys a little bit of context
and that when I came to Stanford I knew
that the entire university was well
known for having
a lot of support for dual degrees at the
medical school almost every student does
not graduate in the traditional four
years they take at least one year to do
something else and when it came time for
me to make that decision I did not
actually know that I was gonna be
business school I wanted to explore and
the primary thing I was motivated by was
I wanted to expand my horizons I knew
medicine very well I knew clinical
research very well many of my colleagues
continue to double down on that I knew I
wanted to do something else so when I
was in clinical rotations I found that
there's just such a big divide between
how physicians think medicine should be
practiced and how healthcare
administrators actually implement
medical practice and I wanted to get to
the bottom of that gap and I thought the
best way to do so would be to get a
business school education build out that
experience return to clinical practice
and then be able to kind of navigate
both sides of it of course I think as
Marianna said it was not a straight line
path for me there are many twists and
curves along the way but perhaps the
most impactful thing about doing a dual
degree at Stanford was that it just gave
me such a broad exposure to so many
things outside of my specific specialty
which was clinical medicine and as a
result I had the opportunity to intern
in venture capital to found a business
of my own to work on a number of
different actually global health
projects and at the end of that for me
the biggest thing was where can I have
the biggest impact the most outsized
impact and at least early in my career I
thought the best way for me to do that
would be to go into venture capital and
have the opportunity to fund healthcare
technology startups that can bring tech
that's much needed into healthcare into
into the ecosystem much faster and much
more efficiently thank you so much and
there was a question in the audience
specifically around entrepreneurship and
starting ventures from being at the GSB
and Norris I'd love for you to share a
bit more about your journey so far kind
of aerospace engineering pre GSB to
starting a company how did the GSB
specifically equip you and helped you
along that journey and why did you
decide to go to business school
I'd given that all oh cool yeah so for
me it's been a pretty long journey to
start the company that I have now which
is sort of the supersonic commercial
aviation company I just really I started
it well I had the idea when I was in
like high school or so there's just
generally about faster flight I even
wrote my admissions essay for GSP about
it and so a lot of my career path
including my studies and analysis
engineer led to that and so going to the
GSB was really the final step for me to
really start this company because I
gained a lot of industry experience that
I knew what the solution was to faster
travel and I just needed to start a
company and so I went to GSB because of
a number of factors one kind of like
what somebody said it has a very strong
Department across the entire campus not
only Business School in his case
medicine in my taste of the aerospace
engineering department and that's where
I went to actually find my co-founder of
why we're worth today so that's that's
one element secondly of course the GSB
is really great because of the classes
the professor's the students and all of
them helps in some way or another I
could be more specific if you want about
helping me and in addition to that the
location is really great like I could
literally bike to several VC offices
between classes after class or were on
the weekends or whatever and that made
it very convenient to actually go talk
to a lot of DC's establish that
relationship with them there are some
sacrifices of course we're starting a
company during business school I spend a
lot of time building a business which I
basically started in the first two weeks
of school so I didn't really do classes
as well that could have my social life I
had to prioritize my might think of
another over my social life in that
regard I mean or could you share one of
them more specific ways in which you
really felt supported or or kind of
transformed on your journey something
that really helped you accomplish your
goals with starting a company you
mentioned that you could
you know was it a class was it a club
activity was it something that you did
yeah it's really hard to pinpoint just
one thing because I mean there's like
tens of things at GSP that really helped
me build the company and right I mean
while I was just finding my co-founder
which is of course a very monumental
part of it and I simply just did that by
emailing some students over there and
got in touch with the right person but
but one thing I'll mention is a
professor on campus and he was on a
board member of an airline and then I
met him through a micro econ professor
who just you know he was talking about
Airlines and I was like hey I want to
talk more about Airlines he's like oh
you should meet this professor and I did
and then he introduced me to several
executives at the airline that he was
aboard of because of that and some of
them still I'm in contact with and have
remained advisors to my company that's
one specific way that you'd be helped
thank you thank you so much and I saw
some questions out there I'm back from
nurture and Michael and a few other
questions related to clubs and
extracurricular activities and so I'd
love to maybe start with sunny wick if
you could share you know what
extracurriculars were you involved in
and perhaps I know there's I know a
challenge of many students is just that
there are so many so perhaps not only
what which ones were you involved in but
what were the ones that were most
meaningful yeah it's a great question I
think you opened it up appropriately and
said probably the most challenging thing
about the GSB is this there's so many
opportunities that it does feel like
you're drinking from the fire hose until
everyone kind of figures out what their
appropriate steady state is and for me I
chose a couple of specific activities
that were helpful one was just choosing
to be in a couple of industry groups
that I thought would give me again that
broad exposure I was looking for so I
ended up doing way too many to begin
with but I ended up whittling it down to
a list that I felt was directly relevant
to what I would want to do which
included the tech the hell
care and the venture capital group I
also mentioned earlier that I led a trip
to Greece that was probably one of the
more intense but one of the most
rewarding experiences I had and that I
got to take 20 of my fellow GSB
classmates to Greece to understand the
healthcare ecosystem there and that I
also got involved in student government
I was the social chair of the student
committee and was able to give back a
little bit to the community by using
Stanford sponsored funds to throw events
parties activities that you know really
were able to meet the entire needs of
the community everything from your big
parties and dances but also events for
children families with children such as
a Halloween trick-or-treating event so
it was a great way to get exposed to a
very broad set of the community that I
may have not otherwise interact with if
I just pursued my academic interests I'd
love to hear more about extracurriculars
just as there were so many questions out
there about them I'm so Marlo could you
also share perhaps what was one of your
and more meaningful extracurricular
activities sure well I think I'm I know
I mentioned one which is that I was
involved in a couple investing clubs
outside of that I also actually helped
form a new club with a couple couple
friends I met first year which is a
really cool experience so we started a
Stanford chapter of what was called the
Adam Smith Society just kind of a free
market oriented club that had some
chapters in other areas and it was a
really cool experience we got a lot of
support from the school to get that
started we actually are I think 2nd year
won an award for kind of best new
chapter which is exciting and had a
decent cohort of people who are involved
we had speakers come through and whatnot
it was a very cool experience to see
something kind of net new brought to the
school awesome thank you and there are a
couple panelists
and Sauron who specifically on questions
to mariana that we want to follow back
up on about pivoting into tech and
product management and so I'd like to
know from you just what courses really
helped you hone in on product management
perhaps and then also you mentioned you
had started your own company afterwards
so similar to Norris the question of
just what what helped you from the GSB
kind of go down that path however you
supported whether it was classes faculty
classmates just your experience in terms
of pivoting careers but also
specifically into tech and product
management yeah so becoming a founder
came first and I sort of figured out
that when then all the things you can do
in tech products what's interesting for
me through that experience so becoming a
founder it sort of came through a few
things so one is that a business class
just like learning about the survey of
tech companies and how to sort of splice
through the ecosystem to is that
internship I mentioned and then from
there Jordan came to flurry one of those
important classes was lean launchpad
with Steve Blank and so in that class
it's across a few schools so you pair up
with folks you know who might come from
the engineering school or other graduate
programs and your job is just to build a
business and so through the course of
the class you come up with an idea with
your team and then you're just pivoting
constantly so like every two to three
weeks you're you're iterating on your
idea you're in the field talking to
customers constantly and that class is
really eye-opening because you learn how
to be scrappy like one of Steve blanks
points was that if you never get kicked
out of a store you really aren't trying
hard enough or it's like you just need
to do these these very scrappy crazy
things or to figure out how to get
things off the ground and so that helps
to sort of kind of help me into becoming
a founder at the time we had a program
where for a few months after graduating
you can actually have an office
this actually worked out of an office at
the GSB for a while which is great and
then from there I ran my company and the
sort of flow of what I was doing I was
doing all the rules you know helping
with design helping with engine size
into background helping with products
helping the sales and I figure out that
like most just what gave me energy
and so when I decided to switch it into
Facebook I pursued product and marketing
and thank goodness for me kinda guy to
be the greatest marketers in the world
I ended up finding the great thing with
product but I think we now have more
coursework dedicated to product it's a
really exciting space it's a very sort
of beta career like it didn't exist the
way it is now years ago and so it's one
where you know having a lot of
flexibility and the ability to really
think on your feet goes a long way we're
just glad what you learn in Business
School and also part of it to be honest
like one of those key skills that I
gained that's really helpful is being
able to confidently make something up on
the spot because I have to project
confidence all day long and like I
normally know exactly what's going on
but there's some times where it's like
you're making what I call 4951 decision
there's a 49 percent chance this and 51
percent chances that but no matter what
call you make e to drive your team
forward in that path and those are the
hard ones and so those are pointing down
51 ones you know being able to sort of
on the spot you know explain help the
team to become confident behind that
idea goes a long way that's thing that I
that I learned through you know a series
of debates and other course work
awesome thank you so much for sharing
and we have a question from Marielle and
I hope I pronounced your name correctly
just what the rule what is the role of
the GSP in the legs of our panelists
post GSP so how have you been involved
afterwards and I first again point out
they're all here as panelists which is
an awesome thing for them to be involved
and give back but because this is the
western region I'd love to have videos
start by answering this question and
talk about perhaps the element it can
you meet up in the Pacific Northwest in
the Seattle area where you're based and
then we'll have someone else share you
know what it's like in a different part
of the West Coast I actually I might
take that question differently than how
you directed me if that's okay Lisa
we do have an alumni presence up here
there are events that happen from time
to time like talks and Thaksin you have
like a summer then every year etc and I
definitely take part in those but I
actually feel like the way that GSB
shows up in my life now is pretty
separate from that which is primarily
like the community of my class and it's
kind of a few specific sub communities
so there's one thing that kind of grew
organically is there's a group of about
ten of us from my class who all have a
deep passion for international
development work in social issues and we
formed a group back in like 2013 or
something and have been getting together
in person once a year and five of those
people living in sub-saharan Africa five
live in the US and we still get together
in person once a year and we have
several kind of meetings throughout the
year where we choose an organization to
back an area we will learn:about etc and
they're just like very very close
friends so that's been an amazing
community just in terms of sharing
interests and also we help you show
their career wise and the other thing
that's been amazing just in the last
month or so is all of the stuff that's
going on right now around systemic
racism and social unrest here in the US
my entire class of 2012 has come
together in this like massive whatsapp
group around
black lives matter and has really been
activating each other and finding
resources and finding actions that we
can take collectively on both with the
GSB and kind of outside in our
communities and that's actually just
been phenomenal like to connect with
people that way and have so many leaders
that have a lot of power out of the
world I'm trying to get activate
themselves to make a difference so it
shows up a lot and it's it's it's the
most powerful part of going to the DSP
is your classmates sharing and let's go
back to perhaps Marlo who's in Los
Angeles so also in Cannon on Bay Area if
you could tell us how the GSB shows up
in your life post GSB women from a macro
perspective similarly to Nvidia said my
class is very close we have all
different sorts of programming and
interaction points even during Tobin
started doing twice a month sort of
career talks where people on Saturday
mornings talked about what they do and
some of the interesting things about is
just to continue to get people
interesting ideas of career paths which
i think is really cool that just sprung
up and then more on the local front and
we have actually a pretty vibrant la
community thinking about even tonight my
class is having to get together to
celebrate one of our classmates to
finishing residency today and there's a
number of us you know on small groups
get together but pretty cool that we
have a tight-knit community down here
that you have especially during times
were allowed to see each other birthday
parties and get-togethers and put clubs
and stuff like that which I think it's
cool especially removed from the Bay
Area thanks and then I love may be I'm
Mariana if you could chime in as
representing Bay Area just kind of what
does the what world is the GSB play in
your life as a as an alum yeah I'm lucky
to fan super close
I think it depends on time so the first
year after the GS viewers who are in the
Bay Area hung out constantly like I yeah
I think I see a GSB or probably every
other day
we are really really really tight its
waned over time so now I have like a
select group of folks who were actually
across my class invidious class who I
hang out with a lot just like group and
then otherwise I just see people very
often so companies in the Bay Area just
absolutely filled with yes beers
including the one I work with now and so
I just normal of course come across GS
beers in terms of formal programming my
class has like are we used to do an
annual football game so a massive
cookout and then go to the game together
and like we'd have like a DJ playing
we'd have like caterers come in it was
like this big deal obviously I don't
think that's happening this year but
otherwise like honestly in the Bay Area
it just happens pretty organically
because if gia speakers are everywhere
and so that's been that's been my
experience awesome thank you I'm gonna
direct this next question to Norris as
the most recent graduate of the program
I'm Jordan in the audience asked just
how did classes adapt to stay relevant
to perhaps what may have been going on
in the world or in business at that time
should you experience anything like that
word you know there was innovation
taking place in the in the classroom
itself by the course offerings I'm
probably like I answered the question
over you hoping so I was really curious
about what GSB was doing with kovat 19
and so I actually knew a professor who I
reached out to for some other stuff and
I asked if I could participate in class
and so he did of course a lot of
lectures around zoom and he did his
lecture on zoom and that was one way
that he adapted the class and I thought
it was actually really well done and
having taken the course both in person
and online I actually noticed very
little decrease in quality there were
still audience or
you know student participation they
brought in a guest speaker as well and
then they the good speaker was really
engaging and shelah disputing questions
as well and they did a case review so
talk about adaptation I mean that was
just like done on the fly and a couple
weeks and that was not just one
professor but it was like an mass across
the entire program so that that's one
way yeah that's and I'm just tack on
that it's something that happened very
quickly and that's great to hear that
you were able to take part in that and
see that experience and perhaps we could
have someone else chime in about that
just about the courses offered during
that time in their relevancy to that
time maybe Sonny you could chime in if
there were any courses you saw developed
or offered that were specific to just
changes happening in business I think
one of the major things that I saw and
was actually a part of was expanding the
GSB s healthcare offerings Healthcare is
an industry that's growing tremendously
quickly and it has been for a while but
especially from the business side the
tech side which Stanford is so good at
excelling they've been able to bring
together even more expertise in the area
and I think that's actually shown up in
either directly as a result of or as
part of student demand at least in my
class I know that the healthcare Club
was one of the largest groups that was
active from industry focus and what I
found was that the GSB was very
responsive and that if they get demand
from the students to explore a new area
find some faculty support launch
programs launch clubs you can as long as
you have student interest you can almost
always get something off the ground and
I absolutely saw it happen in real time
with healthcare offerings at the GSB and
I see a few questions that relate to
just the general why the GSB and this is
a really broad question we only have a
few minutes left but I would love to
and hose that out yet mustard maybe with
Vidya just about not just why the J is
because you've touched on that a little
bit already but uh so how did you know
it was the right time for you to apply
the business blow we're seeing a couple
few questions out there on that yeah I
mean I think there is probably as many
answers to this question as has people
that you talk to you because it's such a
personal decision in terms of timing I
think for me again like I mentioned
before I kind of knew I wanted to gain a
certain skillset that was around you
know understanding how companies work
and understanding how you can well run
an organization and then go and apply
that in the field of International
Development and I felt I had accumulated
a certain number of like years and
experiences out there in the private
sector and I was kind of ready I just
kind of felt like it was like okay the
marginal return of like another year in
another couple years versus going and
actually doing what I want to do isn't
worth it and that so I was I think four
years out when I went to the GSB so that
that motivated the timing it was gut
feel I mean who knows it was the right
decision and then in terms of why
Stanford for me there's there was one
personal factor which is my now husband
was getting his PhD at Stanford so that
was an attractive being back in place
but that actually wasn't the primary
motivator I think I think I could have
easily like moved out and gotten a job
in the Bay Area if we just wanted to be
in the same place I think for me it was
really the combination of things that
Stanford was kind of really
exceptionally known for so one was the
interdisciplinary nature of all the
schools knowing I wanted to work on and
and health care and innovation that was
hugely attractive and really I think was
really truly what everyone says is even
more true once you get there I think to
a lot of focus really on personal growth
and kind of developing as a leader which
I didn't get that vibe necessarily from
other schools that I looked at and is
like the most important thing to invest
and I think in ourselves at that time
period before we kind of go on to other
roles um unless let's just kind of like
the innovation spirit I think that's
part of Stanford which now is like so
well-known and was well known at that
time too but I think there's just
something really
so they're about how you want the world
to be you have the ability to create and
that is like just such a cool thing to
be around even if it's people there you
know I'm not in tech but it's cool to be
around people that are doing that in
tech so it's like a combination of all
those things that felt really special
and talking to folks that had been there
that validated that
yeah thanks video so you guys we have
three minutes left I do want to wrap up
with one question that I'll direct
towards two of you which is we haven't
we've had a lot of folks out there ask
questions around just admissions advice
and just general things like that and we
do have information sessions that focus
a bit more on the admissions process
which I'll talk about in a minute but I
would love maybe I'm sunny and then
Marlow sunny - if you could go back to
your pre GSB self maybe what is a piece
of advice you might give oh that's a
great question
well I think that the probably the most
important thing that I would give to
myself prior to coming to the GSB is
absolutely keep an open mind be willing
to take on a broad exposure but also
don't try and do everything I think the
number one thing that at least I ran
into I know many of my colleagues did
was there's just so much opportunity
that being able to narrow it down to
what you're passionate about is not easy
it's almost like it's a curse of having
too many good options and too many good
opportunities to pursue so while you
should absolutely take the opportunity
to try many different things figure out
what really calls to you and then spend
as much time as you can
pursuing that anything you would advice
you would give to your pre GSB self
yeah Sonny Sonny took my nurses made the
most of the time because there's always
so many things to choose from but I
guess the other one I would say too is I
just want lines with being open minded
and thinking about looking at course
words or speaking individuals that might
be outside of the realm of the
backgrounds you came from I mean I think
about either some of the people that I
got exposed to who just opened my eyes
to
other career paths other ways of
thinking or even some of the coursework
where I took classes that maybe it
happened to fit into my schedule at one
point and it turns out is actually less
interesting classes I took not knowing
what things would resonate later so I
think having that breath and that
open-mindedness to kind of using the
time to have as many experiences as
possible while also knowing you won't
get to do everything is a good mindset
to come in with awesome thank you so
much and with that I am gonna share one
more slide just as we close out this
session with everyone I know that we're
doing a lot of these events virtually
right now at this time but I do in a
share honor on our campus we have a
cornerstone I'm the gun building which
is one of the buildings on the
management and it reads dedicated to the
things that haven't happened yet and the
people who are about to dream them up so
I want to thank our five panelists today
for joining us I hope that what you
heard from them today was inspirational
and motivational and excited you about
the GSB and also gave you an idea of
what it's like to be a student when
you're at the GSB I did mention that we
have a lot of other events offered
throughout the summer so I wanted to
encourage everyone who's on this session
with us today I'm to check back on our
events page and the Stanford GSB
admissions I'm events web page we have
information sessions these are sessions
that include a bit more information
about the MBA program and the admissions
process you joined us today for a
regional panel this was the western
region but we do have industry panels
and women's panels and diversity panels
throughout the summer so I encourage you
to see the offerings and the dates that
we have those on and then we also have a
lot of what we call small group chats at
a broader level you can have a chance to
do a small group chat with a meetin a Oh
an admissions officer like myself or one
of my colleagues or meet a student or
meet an alum of s so again we encourage
you to take advantage of these offerings
we have online
we're excited to have the opportunity to
to share information with you and get a
chance to meet you virtually should you
have any follow-up questions from
today's session we've also included our
email address and our office hours where
you can always call with more follow-up
questions if we weren't able to get your
specific question answered today so
again I want to thank Mariana Marlowe
Vidia sunny and Norris thank you so much
for joining us today and thanks to all
of you and we hope to see you again at a
future event this
[Music]